welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday
as the effects of climate change
continue to accelerate the u.n says the
strongest lever we have to reduce global
warming is to curb the emissions of the
greenhouse gas methane but methane
emissions continue to accelerate cbs
news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff beridelli is back with
more now on a game-changing solution to
slow methane jeff good morning again uh
you know globally methane is responsible
for 30 of global warming and of that
livestock such as cattle account for a
very big chunk about one-third of all
methane emissions but a solution may be
right over the horizon we traveled to
prince edward island canada to meet a
man whose unlikely discovery has the
potential to change the world
the american cure for climate change is
right there in that dope
nature
nature has a solution
always to every problem
just we're not paying enough attention
to it from the moment you meet joe
dorgan it's clear he's quite the
character there's more education in a
turnip than there is in me i got no
education often self-deprecating for a
smile dorgan is being modest he's no
average joe in fact he stumbled upon
what is nothing short of a climate
miracle the seeds of which were planted
through five generations of family
farming along the shores of prince
edward island canada back then farmers
harvested seaweed for feed and
fertilizer
is your stuff here prime stuff
this is what's used we don't take
nothing out of it we don't put nothing
into it this is the cure for everything
that ails anything or anybody while
beachgoers may consider seaweed a
nuisance dorgan knew from experience it
was teeming with potential so we sent
samples of it to dalhousie university in
nova scotia to test for organic
certification
turns out the high uptake of natural
vitamins and minerals in seaweed drove
up reproduction and milk production in
cows joe knew instinctively that seaweed
would be healthy for cows but what came
next was a big surprise research
revealed an unintended consequence
seaweed made cows less gassy they found
out that feeding this to the cattle
would reduce the greenhouse gases by as
high as 40 percent ruminants like gassy
cows have been labeled climate villains
but not because of what comes out the
back you see cows have a very unique way
of digesting roughage requiring extra
digestion and boosting burps those burps
emit methane a heat trapping greenhouse
gas that's 80 times more potent than
carbon dioxide in a year a cow emits as
much greenhouse gas as a small car
so with animal numbers now skyrocketing
to help feed a growing human population
livestock accounts for 15 percent of
global emissions
that's the challenge that motivated
scientist rob kinley who worked with joe
on his organic certification 15 years
ago to find a seaweed species with even
more methane reducing power we started
testing seaweeds from coastal australia
and it wasn't long before the
asparagopsis species showed up and it
showed up in a big way so big that we
didn't even believe what we were seeing
it took multiple runs of testing this
before we believed what we were seeing
which was we couldn't find methane
anymore you heard right kinley's
research showed aspergopsis a common
type of red seaweed has the potential to
virtually eliminate methane emissions
from livestock but there are some
obstacles to overcome first it's not
easy to harvest it from the ocean so
scientists are experimenting with
farming it kindly's team along with
others like josh goldman are getting
much closer to perfecting the techniques
the way that it shifts the ruminant
function in the cowl also makes the
animal more energy efficient goldman is
encouraged by the seaweed's versatility
he says cultivation only takes about 90
days allowing for multiple cycles per
year and it can be grown by aquaculture
operations almost anywhere as long as
the climate is suitable is there any way
to do it for the 1.5 billion cows on
earth i mean that's a big lift isn't it
there are a lot of mouths to feed but
the good news is we only need to feed
those cows 0.2 percent of their daily
ration still there's the challenge of
encouraging cow owners to use the
seaweed supplement
for that goldman says there's incentive
that's because adding seaweed to a cow's
diet means they consume less food
andy says dairy farmers and cattle
ranchers will likely be able to cash in
selling carbon credits for the emissions
they reduce if we were able to eliminate
almost all methane from almost all cows
on earth how big of an impact would that
have it would have a tremendous impact
roughly equivalent to eliminating all
the emissions from the u.s or the
equivalent of taking every car off the
road globally that's a long way off but
then again kinley's work has come a long
way since his initial discovery 15 years
ago this will be a much bigger story
even 12 months 18 months from now you
seem very optimistic i am optimistic as
for dorgan he's nearly retired but his
work with seaweed continues so you
didn't set out to be a climate hero no
no never lost my mind i want to be who i
am an everyday guy whose impact on the
planet is anything but ordinary
now while there is lots of optimism for
this seaweed solution critics say it
hasn't been tested at scale yet and
while it's clear that methane reduction
from seaweed is effective in the short
term there is some fear that its effects
may diminish over time as the cows
digestive systems adapt but the bottom
line here is this one type of seaweed
can reduce methane emissions from cows
by over 90 percent now the challenge is
getting it to all those cows that's huge
and it's a very small amount of the
seaweed in their food it's like
sprinkling salt so 0.2
of the feed would have to be seaweed so
it's just like sprinkling salt on top of
food but not all seaweed is is equal
right and this particular type
aspergopsis say that ten times quick
yeah uh is is is the most potent one but
it has to be grown by aquaculture all
over the world the good news is it can
be grown in almost any climate wow
something worth trying yeah absolutely
regardless gonna take time we're hoping
really really interesting thank you jeff